(vagues)
- C'est frappant, de voir ça
diminuer, là. Ça va vite, à
chaque saison, on voit vraiment
l'évolution.
- On était très nerveux, on
dormait pas, des maux d'estomac.
- On comprend que c'est la
nature. On pourra pas se battre
contre ça.
- Il faut surtout prendre au
sérieux la mesure du défi auquel
on est confronté.
- Le défi, c'est l'érosion
côtière. Un phénomène naturel
qui sculpte depuis toujours les
contours de l'archipel, mais
avec les changements
climatiqeus, Dame Nature est
devenue de plus en plus
déjantée. Résultat : l'érosion
s'accélère à la vitesse grand V.
- Pour protéger le bâtiment,
on a été obligé de mettre des
feuilles de contreplaqué.
- Les Madelinots, comme Jean-
Marie Martinet, sont aux
premières loges des grands
bouleversements liés
aux changements climatiques.
JEAN-MARIE MARTINET, coproprio
et gérant, Le Four à Pain
- On va s'organiser pour
"strapper" ça.
- M. Martinet doit tout ranger.
Dans quelques jours, son
restaurant, Le Four à Pain, sera
déplacé.
Donc, ça être ici, votre porte
principale à partir de
maintenant. Donc, vous perdez
votre stationnement.
- Une partie du stationnement.
- Sans quoi son bâtiment
pourrait prendre
le large. Le restaurateur dit
avoir perdu environ 25 mètres de
terrain principalement dans les
dernières années.
- En moins de 30 ans, il y a
plus rien.
- Plus rien.
- Si ça avait pas été de
l'enrochement?
- On aurait peut-être perdu le
bâtiment.
- Les changements climatiques
font que le niveau de la mer
monte et submerge le territoire.
Et la couche de glace qui
protège l'archipel durant
l'hiver tend à disparaître,
laissant les côtes totalement
exposées face à des tempêtes
hivernales plus violentes
et plus fréquentes. D'ici trente
ans, les scientifiques estiment
qu'il y aura 60 à 70 jours
de moins de glace chaque hiver.
M. Martinet espère qu'il aura
bientôt l'esprit tranquille.
- Bien, c'est notre gagne-pain.
C'est la vie de neuf personnes
qui gagnent leur vie ici,
d'année en année.
- Il en a tellement vu. Il y a
tellement d'histoire qui s'est
passée là-dedans.
- L'avenir du chalet familial,
dit Isabelle Cormier, est moins
certain, lui.
- Ça, c'était devant votre
petite maison il y a de ça trois
ans. Puis une tempête. Deux
tempêtes, c'est parti, alors que
pendant 40 ans, elle était là.
- Exactement.
- Puis elles étaient plusieurs,
c'est-à-dire...
- Il y avait plusieurs dunes
devant votre chalet.
- Oui, oui.
- La maison n'a plus aucune
protection naturelle et subit
maintenant régulièrement des
inondations. Contrairement au
restaurant de M. Martinet,
Isabelle craint qu'il ne puisse
survivre à un déplacement, même
si le chalet familial risque
d'être éventuellement avalé par
la mer, emportant 40 ans de
souvenirs, c'est surtout pour
l'environnement qu'Isabelle
s'inquiète.
- J'ai fait un peu mon deuil
parce que c'était un deuil, mais
pas nécéssairement pour le
chalet, pour le milieu dunaire
qui le protégeait.
- Aux Îles-de-la-Madeleine, la
majorité des gens comme Isabelle
ne parlent plus de combattre les
changements climatiques, mais
plutôt de s'y adapter.
- C'est de l'adaptation puis
c'est de la résilience.
Puis c'est dans l'innovation.
Il y a des gens qui travaillent
là-dessus.
- Et c'est ce que tente de faire
la municipalité des Îles-de-la-
Madeleine.
JONATHAN LAPIERRE,
maire des Îles-de-la-Madeleine
- Il faut changer des
règlements, adopter de nouveaux
règlements, faire des choix,
se reculer, se déplacer,
peut-être arrêter de se
construire en bordure des lacs,
des rivières, trop près
des points de vue ici
avec le littoral.
- La municipalité prend le défi
tellement au sérieux qu'elle
a embauché une personne dédiée
aux dossiers liés aux
changements climatiques.
C'est Félix-Antoine Langlois
qui relève le défi.
Ici, il supervise cette recharge
de plage sur le site historique
de la Grave. Le projet consiste
à engraisser la plage
de plusieurs mètres
de haut avec du gravier.
FÉLIX-ANTOINE LANGLOIS,
conseiller en adaptation
- Cette pente-là va s'affaisser
et elle va s'allonger vers le
large. Ce que ça fait, c'est que
l'énergie des vagues, quand
elles vont arriver, va déferler
plus longtemps sur une plage qui
est plus haute puis, il y a
quand même un tablier qui reste
qui empêche le franchissement,
en fait.
- Sur la route ou
sur les maisons
sur les maisons.
- Le projet de 6 millions
de dollars, financé par la
municipalité et le gouvernement
du Québec, a pris des années
à voir le jour.
- Convaincre les fonctionnaires,
convaincre le politique,
faire des montages financiers,
faire des analyses, étudier
les différentes options,
contre-vérifier les différentes
options, tout ça a pris
cinq ans. C'est un travail
inimaginable. C'est un travail
titanesque, épuisant, je dirais,
parce qu'il faut se répéter,
il faut se répéter et
il faut se répéter.
- Et ça ne fait que commencer.
Les interventions urgentes
et préventives pour protéger
l'archipel se comptent
par dizaines. Le maire prévient
que la communauté de
13 000 résidents ne peut assumer
seule le fardeau financier
et la complexité des défis
qui s'accumulent.
- Ici, il y a un défi qui est
plus grand que nature,
il y a un défi qui est
plus grand, qui dépasse
les proportions de la communauté
des îles. Donc, il faut être
beaucoup plus proactif et
il faut avoir des enveloppes
disponibles au Québec
qui correspondent aux phénomènes
auxquels on est confronté
actuellement.
- Le ministère des Transports
intervient lorsque la situation
est urgente, comme ici, avec
de l'enrochement pour protéger
la route 199 qui s'est fait
gruger par la mer.
Le maire est stupéfait
de constater l'absence
d'investissement pour
l'adaptation et la prévention
de la part des gouvernements.
- Il n'y a pas d'arrière-pays
ici. Le territoire est exigu.
Ce qu'on perd, on le perd,
de là l'importance de le
protéger de façon durable
pour que oui aujourd'hui,
on continue d'habiter notre
territoire, mais qu'on puisse
léguer une occupation de
territoire à nos enfants.
Et à la limite, si on se permet
de rêver encore plus loin, à
leurs enfants à leur tour aussi.
Mais pour ça, il faut agir
aujourd'hui. C'est ce
qui a manqué dans le passé.
Maintenant, on essaie d'agir
en proactivité et d'anticiper
ces changements-là.
- On va à l'avant du problème
et on répare les brèches
qui rendent la digue vulnérable.
On utilise des méthodes douces.
- Pour faire de la prévention,
les Madelinots peuvent au moins
compter sur des organismes
communautaires comme Attention
fragile. Catherine LeBlanc-Jonfe
et son équipe s'affairent entre
autres à créer une colonisation
d'ammophiles sur les dunes,
une plante vivace qui retient
le sable.
- Il y a de l'ensablement,
mais parfois aussi, il y a
la submersion côtière.
Quand la dune est fragilisée,
bien, ça laisse une porte
d'entrée énorme pour les vagues
de tempête, avec des...
de marée et là, ça vient
envahir le milieu, donc
ça vient perturber l'équilibre
de l'écosystème.
- Ici, ils installent des pièges
à homard qui vientnent de
ralentir le vent chargé de
sable. Des cages fournies par
des pêcheurs du secteur.
- On a discuté avec eux autres,
on les a impliqués dans
le processus. Ils se sont sentis
interpellés.
- Une implication essentielle,
selon elle.
- Je pense qu'on est tout
responsable de la protection
de notre environnement. On fait
aussi partie de l'écosystème.
- Catherine croit que l'inaction
n'est pas une option.
- J'ai envie de voir grandir
mes enfants ici et qu'ils aient
exactement les mêmes paysages.
Je ne veux pas qu'ils aient trop
de problèmes environnementaux à
gérer. J'aimerais ça que la vie,
elle soit simple pour eux
autres.